hello
and thank you for joining the agilent
technology cell analysis webinar series
our talk for today is entitled how
intracellular metabolic
change governs immunity and inflammation
my name is david ferrick and i am the
associate vice president of cell
analysis for agilent technologies
i'll be your host today for this webinar
agilent's broad position in the life
sciences includes clinical research
diagnostics
and applied chemical markets with our
many platforms solutions and expertise
we strive to enable our customers
to gain the insights they seek i'm
excited today
to introduce our speaker who will be
luke o'neal
who's professor chair of biochemistry at
trinity college in
dublin um this is luke's actually second
appearance here so we're extremely happy
to have him back
as you many of you know he's been a
great pioneer uh in the field of
immunometabolism
we've learned so much so quickly uh in
the last
five or ten years about how metabolic
programs
can really drive the physical activity
of cells
and really propel them in directions
where we can actually
anticipate outcomes and that's what's
created all this excitement
especially now with the advent of
immunotherapy and targeting
our most native and natural system with
which to protect ourselves
and so uh with that um i will before i
hand the
mic over to uh luke i'd like to remind
you that this webinar is interactive in
the sense that
you can ask a question any time during
luke's presentation
and it's very helpful for you to do that
so at the end when we have our live q a
session
we can get to as many of your questions
as possible uh so with that
i'm very happy to hand it over to you
luke
great thanks so much david i'm very
happy to take part today thanks again
for
inviting me i'm always happy to talk
we're living in a new world i guess
everybody listening in is
same with me in a sense now my lab has
managed to reopen
which is good we're working on covert 19
i'll mention that as we go through so
we're kind of back to normal
but it's obviously a very challenging
time for everybody so i hope you're all
comfortable in your houses with your
cups of coffee in front of you
and i'm going to give you a couple of
research stories i guess
uh one has been published already and
one is the work in progress
which might interest you and i'm going
to cover of course this area david said
the area of metabolic change has really
undergone a renaissance you might say in
the past 10 years or so with many
interesting papers coming out and many
new insights into how metabolic change
then affects immunity and inflammation
my main interest is the inflammatory
process and i've worked on that i guess
for
30 years or so it's very relevant at the
moment of course because of covered 19
and
starts kobe 2 causing inflammation and
many of the problems of that disease are
inflammatory related so it's very much
in fashion i guess and i've noticed
many people now know what a cytokine is
i don't know if it's the same wherever
you guys are but
they've heard of these things and
they're always asking about them and
suddenly now we're all
sort of involved with immunologists
which is a nice thing i guess it's an
opportunity to educate people in terms
of what we're doing
now i thought i might take off a little
bit of general background and
uh the next slide i've got this kind of
concept which
several of us have been sort of on the
horizon for a while now i guess
and if you're a physician you know that
diseases like rheumatoid arthritis
or inflammatory bowel disease or ms or
three are lists here
you get to a certain efficacy feeding
with the current therapy
and it's quite hard to go above that
efficacy ceiling some patients respond
well
some not so well don't stop responding
the current therapies
are useful of course but they don't
really crack these diseases and
the next slide shows you this um some of
the things we're targeting here
and the ones that get to say 50 percent
i'm just picking that number kind of
semi-randomly i guess but you get a
certain feeling of efficacy
and these are things that like block
cytokines block t cells block b
cells these will work to a certain
extent but can we go above this
and can we get this even better than
that and not efficacy saving and of
course the things that we're very
interested in there are different things
and this is where metabolism fits in
because these recent discoveries have
suggested very specific metabolic change
will govern
the inflammatory process but the
particular things listed here the stroma
are very interesting
uh there's more and more discovery there
and subtypes of fibroblasts and of
course they've got very interesting
metabolic profiles as well any stromal
cell will have a role and that will be
slightly different from the immune
targets
and then analogy three inflammasome and
i mentioned that because that's been a
big area for my lab
and in fact my lab got into immuno
metabolism from our working medical
office
and i want to give you a little bit on
that as we go through so basically the
idea here is these are newer things
that you might think about targeting to
increase efficacy in terms of therapies
and you might combine them now
with some of the immune targets or maybe
on their own they might be highly
efficacious and reprogram
the inflammatory process and that's kind
of the overarching idea that many labs
are working on
and these recent discoveries that
support that notion
and the thing we're going to focus about
today are focused on today are internal
rp3
and especially uh metabolism and let me
begin a lot of v3
this in many ways is a sensor a
metabolic disturbance
and i'm sure many of you have heard of
it it's not worked on this and it was
first found by your
chop he said he passed away of course
and we always remember your because he
was a pioneering investigator
it's in macrophages it senses various
disturbances and these are often
metabolic disturbances and then drives
il-1 production the cytokine one
it also does violatine and a type of
cell death called prior process so all
three of those
are being driven by this sensor and here
we see in yellow
cholesterol crystals are sensed amyloid
factors you see those in type 2 diabetes
uric acid crystals down the bottom there
they can be detected as well
b to amyloid and alzheimer's alpha
significant and parkinson's they're
protein options for protein
deposition as a feature so it's almost
as if enamel op3
evolved partly to sense a metabolic
imbalance of some kind and of course you
still don't know
what causes many of these imbalances uh
there's some
information on cholesterol i guess but
overall what causes that disturbance
isn't really clear
but we do know the macrophage can sense
these metabolites and then drive
inflammation
the goal being to clear these noxious
things and of course as well as that
essence of various microbial
factors too so in a lot of three emerges
as a very important sensor of a kind of
a disturbance if you like and metabolic
disturbance is a key part of that
and really this next slide now for me
kind of
summarizes like 25 years of studies in a
way
in that we now think there are four main
pathways at least in my opinion
that drives the whole inflammatory
process and all this fantastic resources
happened
many labs all over the world have
revealed the importance of these four
pathways so on the left it's got the
jack stat pathway
the cytokines trial and then we have the
sea gas thing
that senses dna in the wrong place that
will drive say type one of the fear ions
and drive autoimmunity
then we've entered rp3 sensing noxious
things and that will drive as i say il1
iodine and prior ptosis and then finally
the cnf pathway is one example of
kinases are very interesting as well and
that will drive cell death
and these end up driving inflammation
and autoimmunity
so therefore we think now that we're
pretty close to a good understanding of
these major pathways
uh we know this is potentially true
because of the inhibitors
and there are jack inhibitors on the
market already the flux exact pathway
many companies are developing sea gas
inhibitors to block dna driving
autoimmunity
many are developing energy inhibitors
that will block
you know all these noxious stimuli
driving auto inflammation and the kinase
inhibitors are also in development some
of these are
our early stage programs i guess the
jack inhibitors are the most advanced
and we'll see now
if this actually turns out to be useful
in the clinic and of course many of us
believe it will be
and then our own um discovery back in
2015 with a paper and interlock with
three inhibitors
a drug called mcc 950 that was very
close back in my lab
with like a car with a paper and nature
method on this and and this is a very
specific analogy inhibitor
and strikingly it's working in 53
separate models of inflammation that can
you really believe in a
single small molecule having all these
effects in these different models
and we're talking about in the cns
models of parkinson's and alzheimer's
and atherosclerosis for coronary artery
disease certain autoimmune models
with rare moth diseases caps is a
mutation and then low p3 where we see
efficacy and then certain infections
and who knows maybe kelvin 19 and start
of kobe 2 because we know oil one
is in that disease it's driving about
six which is an important cytokine
for cover 19. and in a way what what the
inhibitors would do there is they're
limiting the
anaesthetic inflammatory consequences of
infection so
i mean cannot really be true at this
point i think that'll be true a thing
that acting inflammatory can work in all
these different contexts and of course
that does seem to be the case
and it places nlrp3 as a really
important driver of inflammation
sensing all this disturbance and the
disturbance is often driven by
an imbalance in metabolism and remember
your chef's original paper
in the rpc knockout you got insulin
hypersensitivity those mice were hyper
sensitive to insulin and what we think's
happening there is endology's limiting
incident because the inflammatory
process will cause
insulin resistance and then obviously
seems to be a part of that so again
the word of enelopi3 is very much part
of the immuno-metabolic world
now the next slide brings it even closer
to metabolism
because three of these four pathways the
c gas pathway
nlp3 and the rift k plastic all
are involved in mitochondrial sensing
and mitochondria of this function
will link into those pathways
mitochondrial dna
will be an agonist with c gas it can
also get sensitional or p3
things like rods are coming out of
mitochondria to modulate the rib care
pathway for instance so suddenly
mitochondrial aberration if you will
is a driver of these various
inflammatory pathways and of course we
knew for a long time
that mitochondria were tied into the
inflammatory process in various ways
and in the last sort of five or six
years i guess some of the mechanistic
links
from the mitochondria to these
downstream pathways have become all the
more clear
and therefore mitochondria get our
attention in more and more detail
and really the next slide shows you the
kind of overarching principle here that
what's really happening is a metabolic
reprogramming event
that's been driven by inflammatory
stimuli or by noxious metabolites or
whatever it might be
you get metabolic change inside the
cells and this could be a t
cell or a macrophage and that metabolic
reprogramming alters the scene of type
of the cell
so now we get a change in gene
expression that's inflammatory and that
might promote disease
and that's the kind of new thing and
david did um refer to this in a way
so metabolism went from just being to do
with say biosynthesis
or bioenergetics it's now seen
at least in this context as the driver
of the senior type of
cell and have you measure this metabolic
change you can predict the phenotype of
the cell and then maybe alter it by
targeting that metabolic change and
that's the kind of overarching concept
that's emerged
most recently and one really good
example of this
is in the last couple of slides so now
chandelle who many would have heard of
he's a real pioneering
mitochondrial investigator has a great
book called navigating metabolism
and i'd recommend it to people who want
to get up to speed it's a really good
sort of a
pretty short-ish account of metabolic
pathways and their relevance
in that book nav towards the end gets
various experts to give their opinion on
metabolism
and where they might be growing as an
area and now themselves and this is a
quote from from from
his own book he says metabolism is the
driver and genes are the passenger and
there isn't an amazing statement we all
think genes are so important of course
um
i'm not downplaying the role of genetics
and analysis of different genetic
variants and disease
but nav says metabolism is driving that
change in a way
and part of his reason is um variants in
genes can't explain the increased
incidence of diseases we're talking
about so the increase in asthma allergy
many inflammatory diseases have gone up
and incidences too fast
to be explained by genetic change which
is what he says what has changed
is our diet the environment and behavior
and guess what metabolism is sensing
those things is poised
to detect those changes and then change
gene expression and cause disease
and of course understanding this then
might provide new targets
and of course a major reason for this is
epigenetics
this is very important because we think
one way that metabolic change ties into
a gene expression change is through the
epigenome
and acetyl-coa federation alpha-kg is a
co-factor for d-metalases that might
affect histones of dna succinate can
block them now there's a very important
finding
there's two krebs cycle intermediates
directly controlling dna
methylation status and histone
methylation status through the role of
these two coal factors
and entirely carbon-1 metabolism is
needed for methylation reactions and of
course that brings you into
you know methane is on the thymine and
the whole area of folate
and how carbon 1 then controls
methylation states of dna
and histones and that's why we think
metabolism connects into the epigenetic
change and maybe changes in metabolites
then
could impact on the epigenome and that
will then give rise to disease and
that's kind of an area that's still
very much being explored and that's why
now would say
metabolism is the driver and genes of
the passenger because it's going to have
a metabolic change is driving a gene
expression changes
and that's a very important kind of
concept for us to consider
now let me now get in a bit more detail
so so the other thing to say is we do
think that uh this metabolic shift
complex though it might be can be kind
of summed up in one word that's warburg
metabolism
that was first seen in tumors by anna
rover of course and the same seems to be
happening in inflammation
and what it means is a change in
glycolysis and it's aerobic glycolysis
is how warburg defined it
i'm inclined to use the word aberrant
because you get strange
alterations in glycolysis with roles for
enzymes in various contexts and then
secondly and very importantly
mitochondrial dysfunction
and that's as important as the changing
glycolysis so both of these
are driving them this inflammatory
process and it
ties into the original warburg effect so
that's a very important kind of idea
and also then an interesting finding
which i'm highlighting recently is
how mitochondria again are so important
for warburg
and then secondly mitochondria are now a
very important organelle
and this diagram here shows you uh
how publications have changed and look
at this beginning in about 2010
pub papers on mitochondria began to
overtake the nucleus
but suddenly mitochondria is much more
prominent as an area and we think that's
because of immune metabolism
but i mean immunologists begin to look
at the mitochondria and publish on the
more and more
the nucleus falls behind look where
pearl golgi is if you work on the golgi
you're a loser look at that
atrocious so work on mitochondria
because it's very exciting and all these
insights
are giving us you know massive new
things to think about in terms of
therapeutic options and how the
mitochondria might be working
in the context of an inflammatory
process
now another great phrase i've used
metabolism from genetics
now i'm not knocking yet it's extremely
important of course it is
and it's the interplay between the two
that we count i suppose ultimately but
remember
metabolic change is as important as any
genetic alteration you might detect
now let me get down to some
nitty-gritties i'm going to give you two
examples
from my own lab and say one's been
published the first is on pkm2
it's very important means i mean
glycolysis and we've got a key role for
pkm2
inflammatory macrophage activation and
then more recently in 2017
after this i'm going to give you that
story and the second story is all about
succinate
and i'd accommodate two very important
krebs cycle intermediates
and we've been publishing on this in the
past couple of years and i'm going to
give you a new story about economics
that i think is very important and it
brings you back to that law of e3
as you'll see when we get to that part
of the talks there are my two kind of
research based stories i'm going to give
you today
now first of all pkm2 it is a
fascinating enzyme
it's the last enzyme glycolysis that
converts pep to pyruvate which you can
all be familiar with
that's the tetrameric form of the enzyme
a lot of what's gone into this over the
past
20 30 years but a tetramer drives
glycolysis
sometimes it's a dimer and it seems to
oscillate between a dimeric form
and a tetrameric form and various
cofactors can affect this say car
is one thing that's one that drives the
testimony for instance
uh fructose bisphosphate will drive the
tetramer and that would promote
glycolysis because that's a feed-forward
loop
but the dimer turns out to have a
different function and that again with
some people i'm
going to hide in the various labs and
shown this it goes to the nucleus
incredibly
non-enzymatic function from protein
expression and that's a separate
function we call this
moonlighting is a word that's sometimes
used it's a different job
from the main java this enzyme and so
therefore this suddenly becomes a very
interesting biochemical
phenomenon the role in the nucleus seems
to be as a co-factor for transcription
and as you see hip one alpha is a very
important part of this
and my lab in 2016 then could show
the dimeric form of pro-inflammatory as
we've seen in a minute
the testament was anti-inflammatory so
suddenly an enzyme glycolysis
that that was a key enzyme for that
process had role in the inflammatory
process
based on methodological state and we had
a paper on this in 2016.
and that paper showed the following data
where the dimeric form in macrophages
now our main
model system is lps driving macrophage
activation like a generic
inflammatory stimulus the diver goes to
the nucleus
after lps interacts with hif and hip is
a very important cofactor this is first
shown by greg cement actually
and this happens in humans as well by
the way and we can say the same thing in
macrophages
and guess what oil one of the hypotenuse
gene not only that but all rather than
things like cholesterol so you're
boosting the warburg effect
through this process by inducing many of
these enzymes in glycolysis and very
importantly
there's a small molecule that can stop
that and form a tetramer
and that was first developed for tumors
by the nci because again zymetic ktm2 is
the facial tumors
and we could show those molecules to
block ir1 they were anti-inflammatory
because they were forcing this tetramer
and there was no longer a dimer to
interact with hif to drive r1 gene
expression
and these small molecules are very
interesting because they're a prospect
now
as a therapeutic and what we also saw
that's important is if you go into evo
and we often go on vivo because when
you're in vitro you've got cells and
culture
the medium is very defined and some of
the metabolites are not necessarily what
you would normally see
so so we'd like to see uh more evidence
for our overall
conclusion in vivo situation and this is
giving mice lps
they may glow the vile one you'll see on
the left there give them this
tetramerizer called tet46 and look what
happens
they make a lot less il1 and on the
right they make more l10
here we have a shift in the phenotype of
the macrophage
away from il-1 towards il-10 by driving
tetrameric ptm2 and that really
illustrates how important the oligomeric
state of this enzyme is and that we
probably said as i say about four years
ago now
and then more recently we wondered about
t cells
and a post that came to my lab from
verona
he always said that don't pronounce his
name right i did my best there stephanos
anyway he was a t-cell biologist he
worked on ms
under all the t-cells and he said to me
let's work on pkm2 and t-cells
and strangely it had been neglected
there was a couple of papers
historically but not much was known
about the role of pkm2 and t-shirts so
of course we began to work on this
and first of all we could show very
strong pkm2 activation
after t cell stimulation without
exceeding three c 28
here we see pkm2 being prescribed a
marker of activation of serine 37 on the
left
on the right it goes to the nucleus look
at this by 48 hours this taking this all
down to the nucleus
after t fluctuation but it suggested a
roll for pkm2 just like in the
macrophage
in driving t-cell activation and then of
course we got our inhibitor our
tetramerizer
gave that to t cells and look what
happened it was especially got a block
of th17
and here we see tier 17 differentiation
by fax profile you see for 28
going down to eight percent if you test
summarize pkm2
there is the levels of rl17 being
suppressed in the histogram
various transcription factors are also
one of the zero houses blocked
there for instance in that panel so it
seemed as if pkm2 was especially
relevant
for th17 cells it was also important for
the one test
and here we see inhibition of
interfering gamma production if you
catch from our eyes pcm2 who would have
thought that would be
a factor in two cells and it is here we
see in the past profile of any an
inhibition of them interfering gamma
production
and there's the quantification eoms was
the transcription factor that stood out
there
that was being inhibited so suddenly
there was a role now
a dynamic pkm2 in inflammatory t cell
activation
and then even more interestingly the t
cells begin to look more like key rings
and as many will know t-rex aren't you
and here we see
increased flux p3 if you check summarize
pkm2 in the top panel
middle panel in th17 polarizing
conditions again we got a boost in the
fox p3
and then t81 again there was a boost in
fox c3 so again it seems
that kkm2 is governing the phenotype of
the t
cell and then the various downstream
things that p3m2 regulates cmic is
downstream
m4 is downstream and hits as i mentioned
and all three of these are inhibited
if you touch them around pkm2 you can
see in the blood
on the left mick is being suppressed
this in the middle and their m2
on the right all of those are blocked if
you set them right pkm2
and we get a big on a seek analysis a
gene expression and t
cells green means inhibited and you can
see here whole sets of make dependent
chains are blocked
by decentralizer whole sets of this one
up
against the block as well and some of
the mtar dependent genes are blocked so
all these downstream consequences are
being inhibited
and here we have seahorse agents are
wondering when i'm going to mention it
of course we did have a lot to see horse
analysis here and we used seahorse
temperatures
right here that was suppressed by the
oval
and the capacity was also blocked and
again the reason for this we think is
suppressing hip-dependent genes and some
of those are in glycolysis and on the
very right-hand side then
many of the genes are hip dependent and
the green means down
and they're being repressed by the
tetramerizer and that's why you're
blocking the rays and the capacity
in terms of glycolysis in t cells if you
testimonize pkm2
and then we um we also uh i guess more
that's saying that again if there's i'm
tall being inhibited again
just in particular and then there's my
again my seahorse profile there
where each other is being measured and
then we see the section wires are very
clearly blocking that
same data on the last slide just just to
take that data for this particular talk
so again we're blocking glycolysis
effectively and the seahorse reveal that
result first which is really neat
and then we go on vivo again i've
mentioned aviva before
um here's a model of uh autoimmunity
many are completely reduced to
demolition level it's very much th17
dependent
we gave the mice test from ours and look
what happened delayed onset of the amino
acid and those voices in the left-hand
side
didn't lose weight in the middle there
and there's the quantification so again
an anti-inflammatory effect in a th17
independent modeling vivo
with a molecule that remember forces
tetramerization of ptm2
and then we also do the next vivo
challenge because of course the
macrophages
and dendritic cells would also have this
phenomenon they could be the reason
for the anti-inflammatory effects so we
took out t cells from the mice
gave them test 46 to test memorize all
the pkm2
put them back in and along with how they
are protected we see suppression
of the ae again by transferring in those
t so into the mice
and the weight loss is also blocked if
you have these these t
cells that have been 46 treated so that
gave us even more confidence that this
is a very important event
let's suppress inflammation and what
this means that is this moonlighting
role
this dimertic role because remember all
that data i showed you
was a small molecule forcing the
tetramer which was inhibitory
the dimers needed for these inflammatory
events and it's not just
macrophages it's also in t-cells is the
important thing
and i kind of showed this as a way
because we know metabolism is intensely
complex
pkm2 is a primacy we think at least in
these studies the dimer
is driving hiss driving mtor and driving
seamless and there's also other people
who thankfully have got the same betters
no more papers came out i mentioned one
by cody or murray
from birmingham he links the diameter
stacks in t-cells
and there's knock-down data as well not
just small molecule data so
several labs now confirmed the central
role for this timer
in driving these inflammatory events and
of course they're very important
at the scene of typical change and this
slide captures that
now remember i told you already about
the macrophage so you need diuretic pkm2
to drive inflammatory macrophages
if you force the tetramer you get an
anti-inflammatory macrophage
equally you know with t-cells you'll
push things towards t-rex
if you give them tet-46 the tetramerizer
and you'll suppress th17 development and
it turns out many metabolic inhibitors
can do this
to the oxygen glucose rapamycin dimethyl
humerate which of course is used
to treat ms dfmo is a polyamine
synthesis inhibitor
and dj cruciate with some very nice data
and probably the only metabolism being
required
for 2017 differentiation if we block any
of those
the t-cell becomes more t-reg-like and
that's
compelling we think because here we have
a metabolic process which is driving the
phenotype of the t
cell which you can target with small
molecules and of course you can see
therapeutic potential
in this because the inflammatory
stimulus might still be there
but now we're getting a two-legged
population instead of a th17
by say culturalizing pkm2 telephotic
that might emerge from all this work now
my second topic then is uh the two krebs
cycle metabolites
my lab has worked on credit cycle on the
throttle in the metabolism
for quite a few years now i made a paper
in 2013 on success
coming off krebs as a key inflammatory
signal and then more recently
and other craves arrived in tablet i
just i'm going to mainly talk about
incarnating this talk today
i remember reminding our credit there is
a famous club cycle
it is the central metabolic hub you
would all have learned that we all know
about electron transport
and then the h every http coming off
krebs driving electrons through the etc
to drive atp production that was its
traditional role but remember you can
make amino acids from crabs for protein
synthesis
you can make purines and perimeters and
ketone synthesis
and lipids from citrate of course for
membranes so it is the central hubal
metabolism
so in some ways it wasn't that much of a
surprise when we've been able to see
changes in credits
in macrophage activation and some of
these metabolites then having
interesting properties and that's been a
focus for my lab
for the past i guess six seven eight
years now and remember this might be the
way we all
remember crowds learn the krebs cycle
forget the krebs cycle repeat you all
can identify with that can't you
so it's been a challenge for students
for many years uh and we see it in a
textbook thing don't we and yet these
latest discoveries
make crabs really interesting or will i
use the phrase why not we've made creds
great again
because of all these recent findings to
do with the immune system
and the kill i want to hone in on now a
succinate
anita tummy now supplement is in krebs
and as i've said before it's got a key
inflammatory role
identity system it's coming off crest
and the enzyme iog one
also called card just to kind of kp
carboxylate
takes the connotate from cribs and makes
xyz and that's what i'm going to talk
about that diversion
and i think in many ways this is the
best example we have
of the metabolic reprogramming events
where you're taking something away from
that one metabolic pathway
making something else as opposed to
ramping just wrapping stuff up
this is truly programming we feel and
there is the structure and
the bottom line is evidence from my life
and many labs now
says yesterday is a potent amino
modulatory metabolite
and the really is the skewing as i say
away from crowds what this is all about
now just before i get into it um there
have been a literature
analytic as an antibacterial agent and
this is back maybe in the 70s and 80s
people got evidence for this initially
the rise of carnage
can kill bacteria and this seems to be
true so one reason the microphage makes
it
is that this bacterial cyber property
and it blocks various pathways in
bacteria it's got dark sides shunt in
the middle there
it's common in savorious and tb for
instance so
if you block that in bacteria you will
see an antibacterial effect and i have
in this literature
bouncing around and this is a nice
rewritten by carson hiller alessandra
nicolucci they're very important he was
the people who told us that irg1 is the
enzyme that makes out
honey its function wasn't known of the
first minute change but it was the
enzyme that makes psychology a very
important starting point in many ways
for this immunomodulatory field to do
with ida connie
and then um i wanted to highlight this
paper i told you this last friday at
another webinar
uh alex princess rob and sebastian
raquel
the lovely paper about to come out and
sell metabolism so i'm giving them a
plug here
i recommend you keep this paper i didn't
using views on it that's why this
diagram the figures are made up for the
news and it's literally only
last friday and what's very interesting
is certain bacteria
of course hydrochlorics can target them
but guess what
they evolve away around this and
pseudomonas
in cystic fibrosis that's the main focus
of alice's paper
it drives by becoming a production just
like lps would do
and has lps anyway and that now is
actually
feeding the bacteria so pseudomonas has
evolved a way
to digest hydrocarbonate and use it as a
carbon source
it also along with lps on its surface it
will be anti-inflammatory as you can see
meanwhile allison's group also shows
just like we could repeat our stuff like
the comic box island one
and that as a show in a minute is a very
important part about this metabolite
does and again that will be
anti-inflammatory
and then the biofilm is promoted in this
process and you get things like
alginates forming and they're able to
draw an irs you want
to promote it comic production it's a
great example i think of a host pathogen
interaction
and it further emphasizes the importance
of vitality
because this bacteria goes through the
trouble of driving hydrocarbonic
production by macrophages which then it
uses as a fuel source
and can circumvent any of these sort of
um you know antibacterial effects this
evolves the mechanism around that
to its advantage and you get bacterial
growth and i recommend people read that
paper
that's a really good example as i say of
this metabolic world an immune metabolic
change
having a direct role in pathogenesis and
in the case of cystic fibrosis
you'll see lovely data analysis paper
connected with pseudomonas in that
regard
now also the times we live in there is
evidence by the county antiviral
first of all we showed at the blockchain
wanted to see it on production and that
could have various consequences for
viruses of course
there was a lovely paper in immunity
back in 2019
i decided to block zika viral
replication and make up a test mice
with zika infection by using hydroponics
because of one of our derivatives four
electrolytes
could stop mice dying from zika virus
for the blocks the neurodegeneration
actually and the inflammatory events
that are happening there
there's also evidence of assessing fluid
replication
in cells and that means now it could
have a role in silence probably too
because an rna virus
and at the moment my lab is now testing
this to be honest with collaborators
in holland and belgium to see if i
decided has anti-viral effects
and then finally there's one paper
showing boosting vsv
but therefore there's a role right
economy we think environment infections
now and that's just beginning these
papers are very recent and we'd like to
know more
i don't want to connect those two
viruses and it's one to watch especially
in the context of sarasota too
now remember overall our evidence is
anti-inflammatory
and it does this through multiple
tattoos as we've seen in a minute
uh so you might have a double ramen here
where it might be antiviral
and anti-inflammatory wouldn't that be a
wonderful property to use during viral
infections
including not just starts calving too
but also influenza potentially
and maybe you'll see an antibacterial
effect and an anti-inflammatory
in the cancer bacterial infections so
i've been kind of becoming more
interesting in terms of host defense i
guess
and and then a role in limiting viral
and bacterial
sort of sepsis will be the ultimate
thing we're talking about i guess and in
fact um
here's a slide that shows you all these
different things viruses are doing is
humidity metabolism
those are examples of viruses driving
glycolysis for instance there's an area
that's really
re-awakening that is the reason we knew
just to highlight all the blue ones are
different viral proteins
that impact on metabolism the clearly
viruses are interfacing with these
metabolic pathways
and then with the pseudomonas example
solar bacteria in that case
driving hydrochloride is a fuel cell so
want to watch this area
now why don't i get into it initially
because we've seen
in a metabolomic screen a big boost of
hydrocarbonate production in human
macrophages given lps and look at the
size of that
it's things like all right water
induction of avocado here
you see a lot more in mice actually
those cells are even more responsive in
terms of economy
synthesis but it stands out as a
metabolite being driven in the
inflammatory muscle case an lps is a
good way to drive
the inflammation and magnesium and we've
seen this we didn't have any clue what
it did we just saw the
elevation and then a very important
paper by max artemos
came in and i met max at the time and he
said to me oh we tried to cut it as well
but guess what it blocks sdh that's my
biodiversity
that had been shown way back in the
1950s that i took it like sph
but max had done this based on our work
on succinate where certainly gets
metabolized
by sca to get reverse electron transport
driving rods on the left hand side there
and that drives hiss
max was showing this is a negative
feedback regulator of that process
so the economy builds up in the
macrophage inhibits sdh to stop
succinate from driving raws is the
overall idea and there were two more
papers tecla cordis another key um
pioneering investigator and a lab led by
uh involving a
software channel by nemeth and
colleagues they showed sdh was being
blocked by hypotonic and that's one
reason it goes up
and then we showed there was more to it
than that it could also drive nrf2
at the top of the picture there it does
that by reacting with key systems in c1
but that in a minute
and then max themselves another paper i
had to kind of driving atf
three and that would suppress like that
would be zeta and have an
anti-inflammatory effect there so
suddenly in the space for about a year
a lot more functions were assigned to
this metabolite coming off this cycle
the net output was anti-inflammatory and
the medium or succinate in the last sort
of two years i guess now it's getting
even more interesting
because of the mitochondria you see the
top right hand side there there's a
receptor
on macrophages there's a receptor on
tusk cells that drive wireless 22 for
instance that is issued which lots of
these work
so suddenly these krebs cycle
intermediates have interesting other
properties
outside their traditional role in krebs
cycle and that's where this
and the earlier the excitement began to
emerge so they kind of have several
different functions
and has these anti-inflammatory effects
and just briefly on the um
oh by the way the seahorse made a bigger
part and of course
in our paper we showed a very good
effect on respiration now
again this is consistent with uh with
the effect on sdh
it's not a great sdh inhibitor in our
hands you need a lot of
uh to kind of see that and here we are
sometimes
again using the oxygen consumption rate
using a seahorse of anabolism rather
than the sea horse analyses
and clearly can impact on respiration
through effects on sta so that is part
of its mechanism you know gonna get the
main part
but it certainly is part of the picture
monomites the classic sdh and everybody
you see in the blue there much
more potent than a technique blocking
that oxygen consumption rate
so that's part of our data based on sea
horse analysis
now some of the evidence then there's
anti-inflammatory we gave it to mice
and love behold it protects against cell
pst us a very clear systemic
anti-inflammatory response you can't
protect them fully because
it's not a drug you know we just gave it
as a tool compound but there you can see
delaying
lps lethargy by getting myocytoconate we
knocked it knocked down the enzyme irg1
in human macrophages and that would make
it of course and lo and behold
you do style one because you're losing
an anti-inflammatory processed very nice
dating human which is important
and then mihai natalia and colleagues
had a very nice paper last year as well
uh
showing that itoconic was part of
immunoparalysis reception
and as as many of you may know lps will
drive a sort of an immediate paralysis
response you get suppression
intolerance the knight economy to sdh
inhibition
is a key part of that process the thing
must be the glucan
which can suppress this immuno paralysis
suppress iog one and that was miho's
paper again
speaking to white to kind of having this
anti-inflammatory
immunomodulatory effect and that kind of
added to some of the work that we used
which is quite nice now our work on nrf2
and i'm going to mention it very briefly
because you probably just a year and a
half ago now
we've got that is good and ryan in my
lab as i just used none of that
we're doing all this work and it didn't
say to me it looks like steroids
it does indeed chemically you can see
that and fumarays can react with
cysteines
on proteins it's called succination that
reaction just to confuse us
and we wondered them without the kinetic
also be cysteine reactive
based on its chemistry and long behold
it is and the first thing we found was
key one
and that would drive on our f2 which
drives antioxidant antioxidant gene
expression with at least 50 proteins
undergo this modification that ldh is
there interestingly
so have suppressed glycolysis by
modifying ldh we had a big interest in
that and xna one and
one prostaglandin that gets modified as
well so it turns out a whole set of
proteins
are modified by tachometers and on a
paper last year by two women and
colleagues in nature chemistry
they had another method to measure this
they'd seen our paper and they came up
with a second method
to measure cysteine modification
anything like constellation-based method
and just like us they found the h
modification about half the things we'd
seen they saw as well which is always
reassuring because they could confirm
our work but they honed in a glycolysis
aldolase was inhibited
and got the h and these were undergoing
cysteine modification as well
so that brought glycolysis fairly into
the picture and
it turns out diameter of fume rate also
targets captain h
as this fourth octal that's what up 401
is one of our derivatives and another
paper has shown
that ph modification so many ways that
d8
became a focus because that seems to be
especially reactive and maybe some of
the potency
of dimethyl fume rate in autoimmunity
because it is used for ms remember
might be to mimicking a technique in
some ways it might be just
sort of a a chemical that can mimic a
natural process there's a possibility
that
people got lucky basically with dms and
showed it was doing the same thing with
mechanics but simply the system
reactivity
has become a big focus on my lab now
it's fairly following up on many of
these modifications
by the way we've seen the same effect in
a way we looked at ig-1 not that
macrophages
um and they can't make any attacking and
it turns out all these enzymes
glycolysis were boost
in those macrophages so again there was
a tie-in to glycolysis here we've seen i
calculate limiting glycolysis in various
ways
not just through inhibiting a uh these
are metabolites by the way there's
either
a blood vessel intermediates being
suppressed here but if this we think is
consistent with the
tubes work on modifying enzymes and
glycolysis and suppressing glycolysis
you're not going to rg1 let's attacking
all these metabolites go up
so what this means is glycolysis now
joins the picture
so we've got we've got sch8 innovation
down the bottom we've nrf2 being driven
by attachment
we've atf3 which suppresses certain
cytokines and now we see
suppression of warburg if you like from
my taconite
and in my view it's a very interesting
crosstalk with mitochondria
because remember the mitochondria make
the attacking a and that blocks
glycolysis
therefore you're limiting the flux
through glycolysis and that will have an
anti-inflammatory effect overall
so again the picture emerges this is a
very important potentially
anti-inflammatory metabolized doing all
these different things
now finally i want to give you the new
stuff and we have evidence
going back to my very stark innocent
very symmetrically
that this metabolite can affect analog
industry
now we got the idea here initially
because of the roller rod in driving a
lot of v3
and because we've seen nrs2 as a key
thing that was being driven by uh
many antioxidant pathways get triggered
by nrf2
and would they suppress rods and maybe
even an
arbitration that was our initial
supposition it turns out this is not the
case
with evidence now it directly modifies
analogy so you'll just see in a minute
but first of all you know in the indian
standard experiment
um this is your bug standard and amazon
you're driving with atp uh just before
you add the atp you give that
economy and the suppressors on one
production very nice so there's my
gerasen
it's live on the informazone again i
decided i can block that
i have 18. these are all one
measurements by the way we also
mentioned the higher 18 that was very
clearly suppressed as well
it seemed especially sensitive so here's
the inhibition of an lrp3 because
remember
we're adding it now before you add the
analogy to the applicator
and log old the outputs are being
inhibited equally power-up ptosis is
inhibited here you'll see it's atp
and nigeria synthetic can block
paraptosis as a reader for that pathway
we also measured um inflammation
assembly
ask is the key platform that forms the
inflammation
and you can measure these massive
artigamers there's a cross thinking gel
on the right i thought to make a block
assembly of the first qualification
about
specs and again attacking its inhibition
there now of course at this stage it
could have been classified one
okay or some other common component
because you know we were just using
these functional readouts
so we measured two other information
another c4 on the left no inhibition
aim2 on the right no inhibition again
for this suggested specificity
towards energy tree we took patient
samples just to get more data these are
cap spaces they've got a mutation
in analog p3 it activates the protein x
vivo they make loads of viral one
and long behold there's iphone 8
blocking that il1 so the gain evidence
from a patient's
system where you have over activation of
analogy being inhibited that's quite
neat
to back up our data on the macrophages
another piece 11 you can reconstitute
the inflammatory in 293 so it's over
express all the components and then the
uh
the fourth is the bar in there the big
one that's the inflammatory being
activated by over expression
and again if you're over expressing one
we can make a taco
we can block that signal well again in
reconstitution i'll say now
i click on it in liberty which is good
to see and then we've got knockouts of
course the allies you want to knock out
guess what they make a lot more i want
because you've lost difficulty
effects and the black history bar is
tile one being made in response to
information activation you boosted now
in the id1 knockout and you get boosts
in r1 and p20 and the rest is the last
one
there you can see boosting of those
signals uh again evidence that the
amazon has been triggered if you lose
hours you want because
you're losing this inhibitory signal no
effect the main two in those knockouts
is the
important control and two with normal in
the ig-1 knockout
and then of course we wonder what the
mechanism was we took some interest mrs2
knockouts
and long and behold we could sit in here
and the black history bars there
attacking a block and oil one in the mf2
knockout
but it wasn't nrf2 dependence which was
our first idea
and that was a bit disappointing but
still it got even more interesting
because of course
uh you know you have to know that
question the question became could it be
modifying
316 modification components in the nlrp3
and
amazon the two candidates analogy as
well and next seven
this is a specific organizer for the
analogy of amazon
and look at a long story short uh we
copied uh other papers
paraphernalia the compound shown to
modify cysteine
another comical aerodonus there's a lot
of papers on them and
obviously that modifies the t-16 as well
so we knew there was cysteine reactivity
in the analogy system and then we've
done that spec and we've identified
15548 as being modified by a
technique in the of rpc on amazon now
we're still
studying this in detail to make sure
this is the one that's being modified
for functional
consequences but we think the mechanism
involves system modification
and then finally whatever the mechanism
might be that's our suspicion
we add another e3 to the mix and here we
see that more evidence
about the kind of really important
anti-inflammatory because as i said
earlier
nlrp3 is driving many inflammatory
situations
and love behold evolution and built in a
metabolite
to limit that pathway and have an
anti-inflammatory effect so
this finding is important because it
certainly adds weight to energy
as a key inflammatory pathway but more
importantly we need to already
attachment an immune metabolism now
metabolic reprogramming
can impact on that very important
metabolic property but finally now just
think about one more thing um and this
is very recent data now my life
has been closed as many of us have been
and it's hard to get back to this
we want to work on this because this is
a very exciting thing today
uh we we look at human samples again
look at the human is extremely important
for us
what inspired us was last summer
i had the honor to referee a paper on
the structure of the iog one the
carboxylase enzyme lovely structural
paper they can be carboxylase
and in that paper they report different
variants in iog
one now these were in the database we
kind of missed this of a different
variance of rg1 the reason why this
paper highlights about some of them in
the active side of the enzyme
and they could use information on the
mechanism of catalysis to look at these
different variants
and one of them the top one here the
solid human hearing variant
is three times more active that's the
rate of the enzyme there
then the wild type if you like the blue
one is it an intermediate was arsenal
reported and that was interesting but
then look at this
you'll see here different populations
the african populations
have an almost 20 percent frequency
of this activating form of rg1 and that
got my attention though this is
the type of energy but it's much more
active in certain ethnic groups
and then i wondered if you took cells
from these different ethnic groups would
you see a difference in cytokines
and lehigh nutella going back to a great
colorado lehigh from vinyl
i knew mihai and xena had done um
studies on african populated adjuvants
they've got a big interest in
vaccination malaria and tb for instance
and they had challenged african samples
and measured cytokines from those
samples and a genotype
it's a real sort of tour de force we had
and i asked him without telling him what
the reason was
that there is an idea one that the
activating variant could include an
association of cytokine production
in those samples because you mentioned
side effects as well and look what he
sent back
less aisle five in the middle now is the
variant that's more active
less r5 on the right and less gamma in
the middle those two side accounts put
it as being statistically
significant now what this means is we
think that's just the start of this that
variance and energy one
is making more attacking long behold
human subjects when we challenge them
and making less gamma and less ios
in response to inflammatory stimulus and
of course we think it's as i'm making
more attacking
this may have evolved to protect against
parasitic infections possibly you never
know
in other words you're making more
technique to block the unwanted
overproduction of certain cytokines in
the kind of infection that's one
possible reason
but for us it really modifies this
pathway in humans because here we see
people with a variant that makes a lot
of vitality
making less inflammatory cytokines when
you challenge them
and that suggests indeed that the
diplomate is anything inflammating in
humans and we're working
on this more and more of course was a
very interesting last little bit of the
human data there but to summarize how
does it leave it so first of all
as i mentioned analogy inhibitors very
interested in those
and a lot of you see sensing the
metabolic disturbance in different
disease states
will they make this let's hope we don't
know we we have my company emphasize two
of them
uh several we've got other companies i
know uh working
on the back of our paper actually our
paper revealed and a lot of pc was
druggable
and now a lot of people in development
let's see what happens
secondly immuno metabolism new frontier
we're also excited about this data
coming out
now remember if you block that pathway
you might see a therapeutic effect
we know it works already methotrexates
and humans anyway
though isn't it and they've
anti-inflammatory effects
so there's two there and now you were
tagged it's pkm2 gave you that story
and it's economics nrf2 like travis and
rp3 so in other words we
might be able to explore those two
processes further
as a potential anti-inflammatory
strategy to break that ceiling that's my
very first slide
maybe targeting these things would allow
us to breach the
uh the efficacy sealing and see better
therapies for all these diseases
that's the next phase in many ways of
the translational part of this work
meanwhile lots more basic science to be
done around these things as well i'm
sure you all agree
okay so much thanks a lot thanksgiving
he did the work on pkm2 big thanks to
him alex here from another graduate
student done fantastic working on a lot
of e3
all that great i shared with his and
then finally our collaborators
mike murphy in cambridge christian says
that on their groups very important in
many different ways like he is and
they've might have converted gurus
there's me him
up for the work of the human example
richard harvey makes every agent and
he's a very important chemist to advise
us
ronald fisher helps with some of the
system modification some of this has
done gsk
on sabbatical living motors
collaboration that we have there's
very helpful in many ways eoc welcome
ffi and tsk are our funders and thank
you all very much for listening
great thank you luke appreciate it very
much
uh we have a lot of questions you might
anticipated
so let's get started and see how many we
can get through
um as i'm sure you're well aware many
people are trying to separate
good from bad inflammation almost every
age-related disorder has
both qualities potentially uh and maybe
it's just an equilibrium so the question
is
is it really possible to separate good
from bad or is it more a question of
equilibrium and the follow-up to that
is is there a potential weakness if we
intervene and dampen inflammation
especially for a chronic
process yeah i mean this is always in
our minds that's a very good question
obviously enough now what you're trying
to do is yeah correct
the homeostatic imbalance in a way
because the inflammatory process is
absolutely good for us that can repair
tissues and all kinds of things
so you're trying to get it back down to
that state in many ways
and then modulate it i suppose and
that's what the best anti-inflammatories
do anyway you don't want to shut it off
because then you're going to get onto
water effects so
so the trick here is to sort of limit
limited i guess
and metabolism is another option and
there's really good papers showing
that you can target certain metabolic
processes in say t
cells or macrophages and see a
therapeutic effect without any unwanted
effects because the big wording would be
other
cell types might be affected if that's a
different inflammatory cells having a
special appetite like
an addiction sometimes for these things
so we do think it's possible to
get to modulated without turning it off
the first part uh oh the chronic
second question today but i forgot what
the second question was yes
if you're successful in dampening
inflammation especially in a chronic
disease are there any
weaknesses you feel to that will there
be a consequence some
stability or yes in your mind i mean
you might affect repair processes which
you wouldn't want necessarily so you
look out for these things
and then you might have like house
defense i mean that's the concern by the
way but again we think that there's
therapeutic windows here to avoid those
unwanted effects
it got it um so we have a couple of uh
peak
pm2 actually quite a few pqm2 questions
uh
and kind of two parts one we do the
first part which is
um what do you know about the regulation
of the dimer versus the
tetramer is there anything known about
how that's regulated how that
occurs uh in terms of those two species
yeah yeah and some of the earlier work
on this of course we're feeling a lot of
steric regulation
but things like phosphofructose this
phosphate for instance serine
can affect it so there's a lot of
information on where those metabolites
bind
and how they alter the oligomerization
state uh there's also stuff on
phosphorylation i mean it's gonna be a
mystery actually
how you force the dimer we know you need
tyrosine for fluoridation tyrosine 105.
some of the gold factor oncogenic
pathways will come out of that
and then drive the dimer and there's a
this is a serine phosphorylation as well
so it's getting
neglected but that's a really
interesting area to think about to be
honest precisely how you're driving that
diameter versus detachment because that
would give you other options
that's a good question slightly slightly
unanswered at the moment
so part two of that question is um in
terms
of the um pkm2 tetramerization
um clearly showed the down regulation of
hyphen
and some other things but you have you
identified any um
genes that are upregulated that support
or relate to the t-reg development
that's the still the mystery so so we
know you boost aisle 10 for instance in
a macrophage very clearly
and it's a fascinating thing that no way
but think about it for a second we're
given those max lps
that's a powerful inflammatory stimulus
you drive the tetramer and they make
buckets of iron 10 instead
i mean lps will drive somewhere else but
you're shifting it towards that state
we still have another mechanism we think
it's obviously epigenetic in some way we
think and then you're altering flux
through glycolysis maybe or changing
some of the epidemic regulators maybe so
we've clouded her
with a bit of time kind of measure that
it's very hard
in my lab anyway we can't we have
trouble measuring his stone changes in
this way in a quantitative way so
if we don't have an unanswered question
we know what happens i'm as assistant
same with fox p3 again we're wondering
is that some sort of genetic
alteration to boost this expression we'd
love to know more about that it's a
really interesting question
so this is kind of a neat one um in
regards to uh
studying smooth muscle cells um
involved in cardiovascular disorders
and um they now know or at least the
group says that they found that smooth
muscle cells can
trans-differentiate into macrophage-like
cells i don't know if you've heard about
that
uh and then the question would be do you
think smooth muscle cells
would have an immunometabolism or a
balance
that um might be involved in disease
progressions cardiovascular disorders
through this
kind of connecting to the smooth muscle
uh component yeah but that's a that's a
really left
to me that's a left feeler but it's
really good actually yeah because i was
i was very
familiar with that yeah you had a
differentiation process i think which
can drive macrophage
uh production i guess but that's a
really good one to think about
and you'd wonder if that differentiation
process from a third muscle set into a
more macrophage like so
you see metabolic changes it's great to
be able when they seek those for
instance maybe we've done it
uh but to look at metabolic power place
in that differentiation event
and meanwhile absolutely i mean as i
said earlier
there's been over the last say four or
five years people are mapping metabolic
change in endothelial cells for instance
why not three muscle cells i'm sure the
stuff out there on on certain activating
you know profiles or whatever it might
be seeing differences in
metabolic processes there as well you've
got to know if there's
it kind of reminds me a lot of times as
i'm sure you do when you speak to
uh audiences that aren't very familiar
with metabolism like you said they
learned it and forgot it which
was me too and everyone else um i
usually start by saying you know
glycolysis is a great way to move
between equilibriums it can respond to
very discontinuous signals and
be very you know robust and whereas
mitochondria in general tends to be the
home aesthetic you know when things are
you know doing what they should be doing
and a good equilibrium
and it's funny because no matter what
data you see including today's show
today that seems to really hold true
right
and and is this really the balance you
know it's kind of like um you showed
nav's book
um which is a great one i completely
agree with you uh
and you know it comes from kind of craig
thompson you know heaven influence
you know is it really all just about
nutrient sensing and no matter whether
you're the pathogen or the immune system
it's really about
creating a situation where you can most
effectively sense nutrients you know i
i almost wonder
between smooth muscle and macrophage
great point david i mean i mean i've
always felt that the first thing
that cell senses is the nutrient
environment clearly you could see how
evolution then would you know build
stock sensing into other things
and i know initially we would have
thought you're sending nutrients just to
get them as a source of nutrients
clearly but clearly they can be signals
you know and they can drive
certain gene expression profiles to
respond to some inherent environmental
danger
and that's where the shift has been and
that's this has been suggested for a
good few years by the way it's not as if
it was a new idea
i mean emcore study them all let's face
it m4 amino acids
ampk they've been there for quite a
while haven't they we've understood a
lot about them so
but you're right there's something
there's something interesting in terms
of evolution there for definite
and why is it the mitochondria clearly a
lot of metabolic activity happens there
you're leveraging that i guess uh you're
leveraging dna the raws so
so the fact that the mitochondria are
sensitive the membrane potential is
everything as we all know so
the raws so so the fact that the
mitochondria are sensitive the membrane
potential is everything as we all know
so
but there's a lot of interesting sensing
going on here in different contexts that
can become pathological the idea of
course you see
but i agree about the mitochondria it
might be in the ultimate symbiosis that
occurred you know how i'm working for
whatever
creature we are today but anyways let's
see if we can get to one or two more
questions i i we won't get to them all
by any stretch but let's let's try to
get to a couple more
um i really like this one um what about
changes in mitochondrial dynamics right
uh fusion and fission uh
and and this one's associated with
isoconic but you know you you could
apply that to almost any of the
things that you were talked about today
yeah but as as we know there's some
wonderful papers erica
pierce's lab and you know there's been a
few really interesting papers on fusion
fishing hasn't there
clearly uh the the fizzed state is bad
the fused state is good the the mighty
country as everybody knows that
they'll spire better they'd be less
succinate accumulating there
so that interplay between those two
states is really important and then
again the small molecules out there that
can regulate that dynamically you see
so i think there's therapeutic potential
in that to regulate that if you can
promote fusion that's got to be a good
thing
my topic comes into it of course because
that that will deal with the damage
might account to get rid of them
and again the the phys to mitochondria
are more prone to autophagy from all the
usual mechanistic elements there so
i think that that's an area that that's
really fascinating and
again i think a lot of questions that
are well worth pursuing in regards to
that state
right well we're after the hour luke and
i think they turn off the lights
eventually so
again um i would very much thank you i
know the audience
very much appreciative for your uh talk
today both
um you know the high level view of
things all the way down to the details
it's it's always a pleasure and i'd like
to thank the audience for tuning in
uh today and uh hope and it seems that
everybody enjoyed it so until next time
uh again thank you so much luke great no
problem happy to help
you